what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome to pop culture explained and
with the films comprising the marvel
cinematic universe having found wild
success at the box office there are few
people who do not know who stan lee is
but while some may think of him as the
guy that plays a security guard
or a bus driver in his various cameo
scenes those who were fans of marvel
characters
long before they made the jump to the
silver screen know that stan lee
is the architect or at least one of the
architects of the entire marvel universe
and the man who perhaps more than any
other revolutionized the comic book
industry
unless we're talking about roy thomas
then he definitely did more but he never
gets any credit so stanley martin lieber
was born on december 28
1922 in manhattan new york to parents
that were jewish immigrants to the
united states from romania now even as a
child
liber had aspirations of becoming a
writer and like most aspiring writers
his goal was to eventually write the
great american novel now he honed his
writing skills by entering essay
contests which he claims to have always
won and upon graduating from high school
at the age of 16 in 1939 he joined the
federal theater program
a subsidiary of the work projects
administration or wpa
now the wpa was a new deal program aimed
at finding jobs for the unemployed and
the federal theater program was
basically a way for people who worked in
the arts to find work putting on plays
essentially like people with philosophy
majors in college right now finding a
job doing
basically anything now stan worked there
until 1939 when his uncle robbie solomon
managed to land him an intern position
at timely comics which at the time was
owned by martin goodman now stan's
earliest days at timely were devoted to
menial tasks but eventually he was
allowed to write a prose story
storing one of timely's most popular
characters captain america now within
this first story
stan made his first of many lasting
contributions to the marvel mythos as he
introduced the concept of captain
america's iconic
shield toss now not wanting to tarnish
his name by attaching it to a comic book
which
in truth were seen as a source of
entertainment for the masses and without
much artistic merit stan chose to write
the story under the pseudonym of stan
lee
figuring this would allow him to one day
begin writing novels under his real name
without the stigma of being a comic book
writer now when joe simon the editor of
timely comics had a falling out with
martin goodman he and his captain
america co-creator jack kirby left the
company and goodman turned to stan lee
to be the interim editor of timely in
1941.
now although he was only 19 stan
flourished in the role but in 1942
stan lee joined the army with the united
states in the midst of the second world
war lee listed playwright as his
occupation
upon entering the army and was able to
use his writing skills in crafting
manuals and scripts
for training films i really want to read
a world war ii stanley training manual
but interestingly lee shared a division
with another soldier who would become a
pop culture icon
theodore gesell who would later publish
legendary children's books
under the pen name dr seuss now
throughout his military service
stan would correspond with timely comics
who would send him assignments that he
would complete and mail back
going so far as to break into a mailbox
when his letters from timely were not
delivered on time which would have ended
with stan going to prison if not for the
influence of his commanding officer now
when lee's time in the military was over
he returned to timely and was able to
resume his role as editor and it was
around this time that stan's cousin set
him up on a date with john buccock who'd
been a hat model in britain before
moving to the us
now after only two weeks of dating stan
proposed to jones and the two were
married on december 5th
1947. now in 1950 stan's oldest daughter
jc was born and three years later his
youngest daughter jan was born and then
tragically died eight days later now
stan remained married to joan until her
death in 2017
at the age of 94. they lived a beautiful
life together now by this time
superhero comics had largely fallen out
of favor and so stan's writing
assignments were generally in the
romance and western genres which were
far more popular at the time now this
led to lee
becoming disenchanted with his career
throughout the 1950s at timely which had
since changed its name
to atlas now on the break of burning out
lee's wife joan advised him to just
start writing the stories he wanted to
write instead of what was most likely to
sell
however things were in motion that would
change the course of lee's life
forever sounds dramatic the first is
that superheroes had seen an increase in
popularity once again
due to some developments over at dc
comics the primary competitor to marvel
which i'm just going to be using marvel
comics to refer to the company that was
at various times timely atlas
marvel and so on but that name switched
to marvel was basically officially made
in 1961 but the other factor in stan
lee's rise was the return of artist
jack kirby to marvel comics in the 1950s
now with marvel desperate to counter the
success of dc superhero team the justice
league of america
lee and kirby were tasked with creating
a superhero team of their own and so lee
took his wife's advice to heart and set
out to make the type of story that he
would want to read
creating characters that were flawed and
more relatable than the infallible
superheroes that had dominated the pages
of comics
up to that point and so the fantastic
four the first of many collaborative
creations of lee and kirby were born now
as to the role that lee
and kirby would each play in the
creation of the characters that's a
source of contention according to lee he
wrote a synopsis of the story which he
gave to kirby to draw now once kirby had
drawn the issue lee would then go back
and add dialogue to the story
kirby however has stated that this
account is not accurate and that he
plotted the story and then drew the
issue
with lee only providing the dialogue at
the end of the process
now which account is closer to reality
is something that we'll never really
know with any degree of certainty
because both of these men have passed
away what we do know however is that the
fantastic four
was stupidly successful and set in
motion the creation of a number of new
marvel characters in the 1960s that are
still mainstays of pop culture today
following the success of the fantastic
four
lee would collaborate with kirby to
create the incredible hulk thor
iron man and the x-men among others and
would create spider-man and doctor
strange alongside artist steve ditko and
daredevil with bill everett now lee
oversaw
a huge period of growth for marvel
comics throughout the 1960s
not only did he write most of the comics
that marvel published but he was the
primary editor as well
marvel had become the most popular
publisher of comic books in america and
much of that credit
lies with stan lee who made it a point
for fans to be able to get a look inside
the company and know the creators by
name by including creator names on the
first page of marvel publications
and writing about marvel writers and
artists on a regular column titled
bullpen bulletins now in order to keep
up with all of his duties stan
employed a collaborative system with
writers that would come to be known
as the marvel method which closely
resembles his account of the work that
he and kirby did on fantastic four
number one where lee would send the
artist
a short synopsis of the story the artist
would draw it and lee would add dialogue
and then narration now lee also did not
shy away from using comics to address
social and political issues at the time
including the vietnam war racism and
drug abuse when lee was asked by the us
department of health to write a book
about the dangers of drug use
lee wrote a story that saw one of
spider-man's friends become addicted to
drugs but due to its depiction of drug
use the comics code authority refused to
approve it for publication now at that
time the comey's code authority seal
appeared on the cover of nearly every
comic book that was published to verify
that the contents inside were not too
graphic for young readers and so instead
of changing the issue to comply with the
comics code lee published the book
without the seal which led to the code
making changes to what
they would allow to be published under
their seal now in addition to infusing
political and social issues into the
stories themselves
lee penned an editorial column known as
stan soapbox that he would use
to bring to light issues such as racial
injustice and discrimination now lee
stopped writing comics regularly for
marvel in 1972 but remained with the
company as by that time he'd become
somewhat of a celebrity and the
unofficial face of the company the
official face was spider-man but lee
stepped down from his role as
editor-in-chief as well opting to take
more of a symbolic
role as a publisher now roy thomas
succeededly as editor-in-chief and lee
spent much of that time
making public appearances at comic book
conventions as well as making media
appearances
and was regularly invited to speak at
college campuses as marvel comics had
become increasingly popular
with college students all the college
kids would just take acid and read
doctor strange comics that's why he was
so popular but seeking to bolster
marvel's television presence stan moved
to california in 1981 but his effort had
varying degrees of success the
incredible hulk starring lou ferrigno
and bill bixby was a huge hit and
several marvel characters headlined
their own animated series but marvel
never gained the foothold on the airways
that stan lee had envisioned now in the
1990s
lee left marvel entirely but continued
to be paid an annual salary of 1 million
dollars per year
for his contributions in 1998 he founded
stanley media focused on developing new
superhero properties for animation but
some shady business dealings by lee's
business partner peter paul
led to the company going bankrupt in
2000. now in 2002
lee sued marvel alleging that he had not
been paid his royalties following the
hit films x-men and spider-man but would
settle out of court for an undisclosed
amount so it was obviously a lot of
money now over the course of the next
several years
lee would undertake a series of various
other business ventures but none of them
ever really rose to the level of success
or prominence that he enjoyed at marvel
comics however
the overwhelming success of the marvel
cinematic universe propelled lee
back into the limelight not only by
shining a spotlight on the characters he
created but through the cameos lee made
in all of the films which would be one
of the moments that fans looked forward
to
the most now stan's final years were
quite unfortunate and that according to
many around him stan was the victim of
elder abuse in 2018 it was reported that
following the death of stan's wife his
business manager kmorgan had basically
cut off all access to lee by his
daughter jc and others that had been
close to him now morgan was charged with
five counts of elder abuse in 2019 but
is pled not guilty to those charges it
was
also alleged that lee's former manager
gerardo oliveiras
he'd basically become lee's power of
attorney and then stolen money from him
and changed his will
now it's really unclear what exactly
happened at the end of lee's life and
lee himself
appeared in multiple videos once
defending morgan and then once claiming
he'd been betrayed by those he trusted
further muddying the waters of a
situation
that we still know very little about now
unfortunately stan lee passed away on
november 12th in 2018
at the age of 95 leaving behind a legacy
unrivaled by
any individual in the comic book
industry and while there are those who
still debate how much credit stan should
be given
for creating the marvel universe
especially in comparison to jack kirby
those debates really detract from the
contributions of both men what we can
say with 100 certainty is that the
collaborative effort between stan and
jack led
the creation of a slate of characters as
popular and beloved today
as they were when they were created
nearly six decades ago and the fact that
stan was able to live long enough to see
his characters
dominating the film industry and
becoming indelible figures
in pop culture was undoubtedly joyful
for both stan
and the multitudes of his fans so with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an
end thank you for watching i'm just
going to call you guys a rob quirk if
you are new here to pop culture explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
you